[Music]
more thor more korg and the muscular
return of jane foster thor love and
thunder seems like it has it all but do
critics want more thor after thor iv or
are they ready for the god of thunder to
finally get struck down despite the fact
that thor has been a beloved part of the
marvel cinematic universe for over a
decade now his solo ventures have been a
mixed bag where critics are concerned
2011's thor which introduced the
character to the mcu received mostly
positive reviews but was not without its
detractors roger ebert for instance
criticized the film as having a weak
story wrote dialogue and underwhelming
villains
2013's thor the dark world proved to be
even more divisive and with its 66
critic score it was the lowest rated mcu
film on rotten tomatoes up until the
release of eternals in 2021. that all
changed with 2017's thor ragnarok which
saw director taika waititi injecting new
life into the series ragnarok presented
a thor story with a much lighter tone
than previous installments and allowed
its titular character to have plenty of
fun on his action-packed journey across
the universe i lost my hammer
like yesterday so that's still pretty
fresh the film received near universal
acclaim and it was clear to many that
ytt's unique approach to the character
and world marked a high point for the
series as such it was entirely
unsurprising that marvel brought ytt
back to direct the next installment in
the franchise thor love and thunder
however if the initial reviews for the
film are any indication it appears that
many critics aren't as enamored with
ytt's direction as they were in the
previous film at the time of this
writing thor love and thunder currently
holds a 70 critic score on rotten
tomatoes based on 111 unique reviews
while no great failure that is already
lower than the original thor and almost
as low as thor the dark world although
this number will no doubt change as time
goes on the score indicates just how
divisive this film has been amongst
critics as there are plenty who believe
that the film's failures far outweigh
its achievements shiraz farouki of
cinema debate said that the film
represents a notable backslide in
quality compared to thor ragnarok he
wrote despite some strong performances
and a few heartfelt moments thor love
and thunder ultimately buckles under a
slew of tiresome humor and paper-thin
character arcs david rooney of the
hollywood reporter shared a similar
sentiment saying the movie feels
weightless flippant instantly
forgettable sparking neither love nor
thunder other critics including looper's
own larry carroll were more positive in
their reviews of love and thunder those
who enjoyed the movie seemed willing to
overlook many of the film's flaws thanks
to its heartfelt and fun-loving core
they include nick allen who wrote for
roger ebert.com while it has too many
familiar flourishes and jokes this
entertaining sequel is still a force for
good with enough visual ambition and
heart in front of and behind the camera
to stand on its own surprisingly a
number of critics took issue with taika
waititi's direction and writing in their
reviews for thor love and thunder with
some arguing that his distinctive blend
of comedy and drama is part of the
reason that the film falls flat brian
lowry of cnn wrote the impressive mix of
tones and styles that director taika
waititi pulled off in thor ragnarok
largely fizzles in thor love and thunder
which isn't as funny as it wants to be
as stirring as it needs to be or
romantic as it ought to be charles
pulley and more of the verge wrote while
reframing thor as the mcu's himbo god of
jocularity was a solid way of renewing
interest in the character an
overabundance of jokes is one of the big
reasons why ytt's thor love and thunder
feels like an awkward step back indeed
initial reviews indicate that ytt's
distinctive style might be wearing
itself thin within the mcu as the unique
tonal shifts within his work don't seem
to have landed as well in love and
thunder as they have in the past grant
watson a fiction machine asserted the
dramatic and comedic elements simply do
not mix well none of the more serious
elements feel earned and none of the
humorous bits can be taken seriously the
film curdles for all the criticism that
has been levied thus far at thor love
and thunder one bright spot within these
initial reviews is the overwhelming
praise being given to the film's cast
specifically in regards to chris
hemsworth and natalie portman the latter
of whom plays jane foster aka the mighty
thor rohan patel of comicbookmovie.com
called hemsworth's leading man work and
absolute rock star performance meanwhile
alan cerny of vital thrills praised
portman saying natalie portman never
treats this character as silly or
weightless and while many people may
come to see chris hemsworth have fun as
thor it's portman's performance that i
am most impressed with for all the
criticism that tyka ytt's lighthearted
tone has received within these early
reviews one thing that many critics have
agreed on is that he continues to
provide the mcu with fun exciting
characters with performances to match
donald clark of the irish times wrote
for much of the time the love and
thunder audience will extract as much
fun as the cast seems to be having if
that is possible these divisive reviews
are all the more reason to check out the
film for yourself to see where you stand
as it's clear there is plenty to love
and plenty to loathe within thor love
and thunder
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]